[Música]
tras el caótico cara a cara entre donald
trump y joe biden la organización
encargada de los debates presidenciales
de eeuu tomará medidas para poner orden
en los dos próximos encuentros entre el
republicano y el demócrata muy
criticados por las interrupciones y
agresiones de ayer
españa aprobó nuevas medidas contra el
avance de la pandemia que suma más de
769 mil contagios y 31 mil 791
fallecidos en este país madrid es una de
las ciudades que tendrá que aplicar los
anuncios entre ellos restringe la
movilidad pero el gobierno regional se
opone y asegura es una decisión sin
validez jurídica el mundo llora la
muerte de quino el creador de mafalda el
dibujante y caricaturista argentino
joaquín salvador lavado falleció en su
ciudad natal mendoza tenemos reporte
desde buenos aires
hola cómo están bienvenidos a las
noticias aquí en france 24 mi nombre es
alan austria y empezamos con la carrera
electoral estadounidense y es que la
comisión de debates presidenciales un
grupo no partidista que ha organizado
estos eventos desde 1988 cambiará el
formato como parte de una serie de
medidas para poner orden en los dos
últimos cara a cara entre donald trump y
joe biden esto luego de las críticas
generalizadas tras un caótico primer
enfrentamiento empañado por insultos y
ataques personales
joe biden mandó callar al presidente y
trump lo interrumpió 35 veces en su
turno de palabra el moderador pidió a
trump mantener orden en 13 ocasiones
durante su intervención el mandatario se
negó a condenar a los grupos
supremacistas blancos y un guiño a los
supremacistas blancos del presidente de
eeuu cuando se le preguntó si le diría a
los grupos de milicias de extrema
derecha que se mantuvieran al margen y
que no hayan dieran violencia a las
ciudades como portland que llevan meses
albergando protestas
donald trump eludió el tema
casi todo lo que veo es el ala
izquierdista
no del ala derecha y estoy dispuesto a
hacer cualquier cosa quiero ver la paz
como quieres llamar los supremacistas
blancos y proud voice and white voice
apártense y estén preparados los
productos voice un grupo paramilitar de
extrema derecha se apresuraron a
celebrar la frase del presidente
publicando en sus canales de redes
sociales comentarios con la respuesta de
trump el candidato demócrata a la casa
blanca publicó un tweet diciendo que
ésta era la américa de donald trump esta
no es la primera vez que trump no
condena a los supremacistas blancos en
2017 se negó a condenar a los
nacionalistas y otros grupos de directa
después de que un coche se estrellara
contra los contramanifestantes en
charlottesville matando a heather haier
de 32 años
tenías gente que era muy buena de ambos
lados
creo que hay culpa en ambos lados no
tengo ninguna duda al respecto y tú
tampoco tienes alguna vez
los analistas ven la negativa del
mandatario republicano a condenar una
vez más a los supremacistas blancos como
un llamado a las armas el reconocimiento
probablemente apelará su base en lugar
de cambiar a los votantes de bando
nos vamos a europa y es que el
ministerio de sanidade españa ordenó
imponer nuevas medidas para controlar la
propagación del cob y 19 en las ciudades
de más de 100.000 habitantes que hayan
superado 500 contagios en los últimos 14
días esto afecta principalmente a la
comunidad de madrid' que ya anunció su
oposición vamos a este informe de andrew
a mayo
ahora que el frío se instala de nuevo en
españa 10 municipios de la comunidad de
madrid incluida esta ciudad tendrán que
imponer medidas restrictivas a la
movilidad de sus residentes una nueva
acción coordinada en salud pública con
medidas muy importantes en este momento
de la pandemia en relación a unos
determinados territorios de nuestro país
que cumplen unos criterios
y a las medidas asociadas a estos
territorios este este acuerdo ha sido
aprobada con una amplia mayoría 13 votos
a favor una abstención y 5 votos
negativos 13 votos afores y un 70% de
los miembros del consejo le han dado
apoyo y por tanto constituye una
decisión colegiada del sistema nacional
de salud
las nuevas medidas que serán publicadas
en forma de decreto en los próximos días
afectarán a todos los municipios
españoles que presenten más de 500 casos
de coronavirus por cada 100.000
habitantes y una ocupación de las
unidades de cuidados intensivos que
supere el 35 por ciento madrid es una de
las ciudades que tendrá que aplicar las
nuevas restricciones anunciadas pero el
gobierno regional se ha opuesto y
aseguró que es una decisión sin validez
jurídica e intervención en su autonomía
madrid- actualmente es la comunidad
autónoma que está peor y es verdad que
hay que tomar medidas para que esto no
empeore y nos lleve a un segundo
confinamiento
y es y aquí estoy tomando medidas pero
no obstante pienso que el segundo
confinamiento no esté efectivo porque
económicamente españa no se lo puede
permitir porque ya sólo vale ver con los
datos del pib y todo esto que va a bajar
pues que no es viable los habitantes de
los 10 municipios donde aplicara la
medida tendrán prohibido los viajes por
placer y las fronteras de cada ciudad
estarán cerradas a los visitantes
extranjeros el número de contagios por
coronavirus en francia volvía a superar
el umbral de los 13 mil en 24 horas y en
el mismo periodo 64 personas murieron
con lo que la cifra total de
fallecimientos se acerca a los 32 mil
con el empeoramiento de los números el
gobierno está cerca de catalogar a parís
como una zona de máxima alerta ya que
sus unidades de cuidados intensivos
también están al borde de su capacidad
máxima lo que significaría el regreso a
las medidas estrictas de confinamiento
a unos otros temas y es que sigue en
aumento la atención entre armenia y
azerbaiyán los enfrentamientos continúan
en la disputada región de nagorno
karabaj a el presidente francés emmanuel
macrón dijo que estaba preocupado por
los mensajes beligerante de turquía esto
después de que el gobierno turco dijera
estar listo para ayudar a azerbayán y es
que unas 750.000 personas en francia son
de descendencia armenia por su parte
rusia invitó a las partes a que negocien
en moscú
la despedida a estos armenios recién
reclutados que ahora parten al frente de
batalla mientras tanto otros llegan a
inscribirse uniéndose a la lucha contra
azerbaiyán en la disputada región de
nagorno karabaj bueno todos tenemos que
prestar un servicio no podía quedarme
indiferente tenía que venir nagorno
karabaj es un enclave de mayoría armenia
que se independizó unilateralmente de
azerbayán en los años 90 estaba bajo el
control de separatistas armenios y
ningún país del mundo reconoce su
soberanía ambas partes se acusan de
haber comenzado el domingo unos
violentos enfrentamientos que han venido
en aumento también se señalan de apuntar
a objetivos civiles castigos azerbayana
ha estado atacando asentamientos e
infraestructuras civiles desde el mismo
comienzo de la ofensiva y podemos ver la
evidencia de ello en toda la región son
las tensiones internacionales crecen de
la mano del conflicto
armenia acusa a turquía aliado de
azerbayán de derribar uno de sus aviones
militares un ataque que turquía y
azerbaiyán niegan
ankara expresó el miércoles que haría en
lo necesario cuando le preguntaron si
ofrecería ayuda
se sirva ya se lo pide algunos aliados
de turquía en la otan dijeron estar
alarmados por esa postura entre ellos el
presidente francés emmanuel macro afonso
sandwich de minsk con su gol y francia
como parte del grupo de ming se solicita
la imparcialidad que define mi
advertencia y permanece extremadamente
preocupada por los mensajes casi de
guerra que llegan desde turquía en las
últimas horas
ese miércoles rusia ofreció albergar
negociaciones entre las dos ex
repúblicas soviéticas mientras que los
dos bandos rechazan las peticiones
internacionales de un cese al fuego o
una tregua
y finalizamos con un emotivo adiós
joaquín salvador lavado conocido como
quino y quien dio vida al popular
personaje de mafalda la icónica niña
inteligente y curiosa que trascendió
fronteras falleció este miércoles en su
natal mendoza el dibujante y humorista
argentino gráfico falleció a los 88 años
artistas políticos organizaciones de
derechos humanos y miles de sus
seguidores han expresado sus
condolencias ha rendido un tributo a su
ingenio que no recibió la medalla de la
orden y las letras de francia natal yo
que soy nuestro corresponsal en buenos
aires- visitó el monumento a mafalda en
el barrio de san telmo
a poco de conocerse la noticia
comenzaron a llegar a esta esquina del
barrio de san telmo en la ciudad de
buenos aires- ofrendas florales para
despedir a joaquín salvador lavado quino
justo en este banco donde están
representados los personajes de su
máxima creación la tira más falda una
tira que hizo reír pero también
reflexionar a generaciones de argentinos
de hispanoparlantes y también de
aquellos que pudieron acceder a la obra
a través de traducciones que no falleció
este miércoles 30 de septiembre un día
después de que mafalda hubiera cumplido
56 años entre los homenajes la provincia
de mendoza de donde era originario
decretó duelo provincial tras el
fallecimiento del creador del humorista
gráfico de la historia artista joaquín
salvador lavado
llegamos al final gracias por su
compañía ciudad con más en france 24
punto com
[Música]